[Music]
the year 2048
a huge earthquake claimed the lives of
hundreds of thousands of people
climate change has ravaged earth with
increased seismic activity over the last
hundred years
scientists have discovered that
earthquakes were only going to get worse
and worse eventually they would get to
the point of shaking the world
so much that cities would crumble and
oceans would boil
leaving earth uninhabitable earth was
fast approaching
it's used by date humanity started
looking beyond earth in search of new
planets they could settle on
scouting probes eventually return
promising results
on a planet named enoch which will be
able to provide a similar experience to
earth
the major governments of earth combine
their resources under the newly formed
and not colonization authority or eca
soon afterwards two enormous ships the
caravel
and the flores were built in orbit
a group called the outriders was
established to be the first people to
set foot on an alien planet
they were supposed to be the best of
humanity in such a situation
they were mercenaries survivors and
explorers
their mission was to secure a perimeter
and prepare for the landing of the
colony ship
so in the year 2159 the future of the
human species
is loaded onto two colony ships and sets
forth on an 80-year journey through
space
however the voyage didn't start out
smoothly the caravel was destroyed
before it could leave orbit
killing the majority of the outriders on
board
teams had to quickly scramble together
to rebuild units of outriders
based on who was left a large amount of
home were mercenaries and freelancers
with no ties to any sort of authority
unit
after traveling for over 80 years
contact with earth had been lost
15 years ago so regardless of how they
felt enoch was now their only option
leaving the colony ship along with the
500 000 civilians on board
the outriders take landing pods down to
the planet
the plan is to start setting up a base
camp and throwing out civilians
and sending them planetside a few
thousand at a time this would allow a
slow and steady transition
to test how the infrastructure handles
the increased workload over time
however it didn't take long for the
outriders to discover the anomaly
a massive and deadly energy storm the
outright has attempted to warn eca
to abort the colonisation but the eca
leadership
pushed back to the extent of opening
fire on the outriders
the outriders who survived the exposure
to the anomaly and the following
altercation with the eca
were forced to retreat where they
entered a state of cryostasis
eventually the surviving outriders wake
from cryostasis
and they quickly learn that the eca's
attempt at colonization
has failed enoch has become a war zone
the anomaly destroyed all of the
colony's advanced technology
and has forced its people to remain
within the confines of a single mountain
valley
due to the abundance of now hostile
alien wildlife
and rapidly depleting resources the
colonists have been divided
and are at war with one another the eca
on one side
and the militant group known as the
insurgents on the other
in addition certain people have not only
managed to survive being exposed to the
anomaly
but have also come out of it in a
mutated state which has given them
access to supernatural powers
to everyone around them they are known
as the altered
and the outriders coming out of
cryosleep were among these survivors who
had gained these abilities
while the eca may have superior defenses
in the ongoing civil war
the insurgents are being led by an
incredibly powerful altered
so when the outriders came back onto the
scene they were welcomed with open arms
by their former colleagues in the eca as
they now too have the power of an
altered on their side
to fight back the insurgent presence
the commander of the eca talks of a
mysterious signal being broadcasted from
the other side of the anomaly
the outriders meet up with one of the
eca scientists who has the last
satellite uplink that can be used to
connect to the flores
which is still sitting in orbit with the
majority of the colony supplies
with these supplies and a location far
away from the anomaly
they could try once again and establish
a new colony on the planet
traveling through the hazardous and
knock environment avoiding the
increasingly dangerous wildlife and
sheltering from the storms
they follow the signal making their way
through to the other side of the anomaly
along their journey they come across an
alien being called august
august is a native of the new world
known as the pax
this civilization seems to be somewhat
aligned with the anomaly
possibly even able to control it
when the outriders first discover august
it isn't under the best circumstances
the native is being held captive by a
group of eca that have deserted from the
rest of the colony
august is being used as a research
specimen kept alive
to provide bone marrow and spinal fluid
towards a so-called cure for those who
have been exposed to the anomaly
the outright is free august and fight
their way out of the camp
and are now approaching the edge of the
non-human exploration
of the knock in this uncharted land
they come across yet another
civilization native to the planet
but this group is considerably more
hostile and are adequately referred to
as the ferals
however it isn't long before they
realize that august the pax
and the ferals are one in the same
when a member of the group was in danger
and at risk of being killed by some of
the mutated wildlife
august used the powers of the anomaly to
transform into a hulking primitive beast
but after fighting off the wildlife the
beast then turned on the group
in turn the outriders were forced to
execute august
the group continues their journey to
find the origin of the signal
eventually they come across something
that they weren't expecting to see
in the distance they see the wreck of an
enormous ship
and the name on the side of this ship
the caravel and this was the origin
of the signal that they'd been following
since the beginning
before leaving earth's orbit the caravel
had been destroyed
so how had it ended up on a knock
it turns out that the people who were
left behind were not only able to repair
the damage
but were able to rebuild and upgrade the
engines to a more advanced state than
the flores
and with that the caraval actually
managed to arrive at a knock
ahead of them the newly constructed ship
was captained by a man named monroy who
was a survivor
of the original explosion and holds a
grudge against the outriders for leaving
them behind
on a dying earth upon arriving on a
knock
monroy's people were the ones who made
first contact with the pax
but over time monroy learned of their
powers and enhanced abilities
relating to the anomaly and he started
getting paranoid he ordered the murder
of all pax leadership
and enslaved the rest to work in labor
camps some managed to escape
but were hunted down eventually it got
too much
and the pecs began using the anomaly to
turn themselves feral
in order to defend themselves and put a
stop to monroy's forces
the anomaly appears to be a part of this
world and it's the packs that have been
channeling it
and keeping it under control up to this
point when left with no other choice
the pacs turn themselves into the
current savage forms and wiped out the
caraval colonists
leaving the anomaly unchecked and out of
control to violently sweep across the
planet
so the storm that destroyed the
outriders and caused the rift between
the members of the eca
was initially caused by monroy and his
treatment of the pax
after locating and putting an end to the
ageing monroy the group was able to send
the uplink signal to the flores
drop pods full of supplies began raining
down on the planet while watching the
cargo pods land
a large group of colonists made
themselves known
the stories of the outright of progress
on the planet had inspired them to
follow
in hopes that they could finally fulfill
their original mission of colonizing a
knock
and helping humanity rebuild
this has just been a brief overview of
the story there is actually quite a bit
of depth once you start diving right
into the side missions and the journal
entries
these go into detail covering quite a
number of topics from the world of enoch
including its history and wildlife all
the way through to the characters
hostile factions equipment and events
that have happened over time
i'm already scripting up a few and from
what i've seen so far it's actually
pretty cool
i admit i wasn't overly excited about
the outright story at first
but the further i got through it the
more hooked i found myself
for those of you interested in this side
of things there is still a ton of
information to be discovered in game
although the developers of outriders
have stated time and time again that
this isn't a live service game
the story certainly leaves itself open
enough for a lot more story to come
fingers crossed this is just the
beginning when it comes to the outriders
story
anyway thank you very much for watching
i hope you've enjoyed this and i'll
catch you in the next one
cheers
you